[ANITA]: Hello and welcome!
I'm Anita Wood, the program manager for the
Stanford energy innovation and emerging technologies
program, also known as the EIET program.
On behalf of the Stanford Center for Professional
Development and the Stanford Bits and Watts
Initiative, which is in the Stanford Precourt
Institute for energy, I would like to welcome
you to this special session on the transformation
of the electric grid with Dr. Ram Rajagopal.
Ram is an associate professor of civil and
environmental engineering and a senior fellow
at the Stanford Precourt Institute for Energy.
Dr. Rajagopal teaches the EIET237: Transforming
the Grid course in the Stanford EIET program.
He directs the Stanford Sustainable Systems
lab, which is focused on large-scale monitoring,
data analytics, and stochastic control for
infrastructure networks, in particular power
networks, and his current research interests
in power systems are in the integration of
renewables, smart distribution systems, and
demand side data analytics.
For this session, he will be talking about
looking beyond technical considerations and
integrating distributed energy resources.
He will also talk about cyber constraints,
privacy, and energy equity.
Ram's presentation will be followed by several
pre-recorded questions and answers.
Now let's begin.
[RAM]: First of all thank you for hosting
our session just here on the left hand side
of this very first slide, I chose a picture
of something that is hot off our research
to show the power of open data.
We have been able to analyze the demand -- hourly
demand -- from 58 countries around the world
to understand the impact of COVID-19 restrictions
on the demand and you can see here this work
was entirely done by a group of students and
postdocs.
I thought a little bit about what is interesting
today and kind of the title of the presentation
reflects that at Stanford, what is our, some
of our key interests.
These are the concepts I have here: virtualization,
learning coordination, and privacy/fairness
in these consumer driven distributed energy
systems.
This is very important because the word consumer
here means there is people and their preferences
that need to be taken into account, so I think
that's a major distinction of the traditional
view of such systems.
You know we all are familiar with the grid
I'm just going to go very quickly here and
the traditional grid is changing because we
have massive adoption of renewables and new
technologies such as storage at the transmission
level, but at the same time behind the meter
consumers are adopting new technologies as
well, like EV charging, smart appliances,
self-generation through solar PV for example,
and all of these technologies are connected
to the cloud.
This enables us to collect data and send signals
and potentially coordinate all these resources
to achieve individual and joint goals that
can serve, you know, to the wholesale market
so you can have flexible load that follows
generation instead of the other way around,
but also as we start to see of increased adoption
of these technologies, this coordination can
be used to mitigate the impacts on the distribution
network.
So, one of the research focuses here in Stanford
has really been around how do we utilize this
capability behind the meter to support the
rest of the grid ecosystem, and when we say
that what are the key challenges here?
The first one is that we need to understand
what is the real flexibility available at
each customer and that critically depends
not just on the technologies they have but
also their preferences: how much are they
willing to change, adapt, and adjust, and
learning that at the scale that needs to be
done is something that still remains extremely
challenging and an open question and something
that I feel for example you need not just
methods, but a lot of open data interaction
with customers and so on.
The second question is, well, if we know the
consumer preferences and assuming we have
a model for the distribution network, then
we can start to think about how to scale this
coordination to millions of heterogeneous
resources.
Again the key word here is scaling there is
many many strategies and architectures for
coordination; this is very well known, but
do they actually scale to the scale we need
them to go?
The third one I think is very critical and
goes into the economics and policy because
it is all about whatever strategies you create,
whatever platforms, ideas, etc, be it to collect
data or to coordinate, you definitely need
to make it easy and attractive for consumers
to engage.
That means not asking them tons of questions,
you know, or are asking a lot of effort on
their part, and also mechanisms to compensate
them.
Last but not least I think we're seeing a
dramatic change in society today regarding
two ideas and I think it's time we took them
more deeply into how we design these energy
systems, particularly consumer driven ones.
One is this notion of privacy, we are very
familiar with this, there was some early work
on this looking at privacy of smart meter
data and so on, but in those days, the entity
that took care of the data was just the utility.
So the privacy was in a way managed by utility
regulators, but now we're talking about aggregators,
different types of service providers, and so
on; we need a broader and expanded definition
of what privacy is, and actually ways to enforce
it, monitor it, measure it. And the second topic
I think is one of fairness, so I will address
those briefly at the end of the presentation.
What we mean by fairness is we need to give
both equal access to the participation in
these modern systems, but we also need ways
to ensure that the systems we create don't
exploit particularly vulnerable customers,
so you know, families who have lots of people
who stay home tend to be lower income, and
maybe your demand response algorithm would
continuously target them for turning on and
off. These are considerations that have been
taken into account in economics and more now
on web search and things like that, but I think
there's a whole open question about how to
do this from a technical perspective, but also
institutionally how utilities and companies,
aggregators, technology providers, policy makers
are going to deal with these issues. I just
wanted to kick off the conversation with something
that we did recently which is kind of unusual
here for our group. We worked with a sociologist
and a psychologist to try to understand in
a real population how much actual consumer
flexibility there is on their loads and devices
that you see. And in this graph here, what you
see is really what percentage of each one
of these activities is performed during the
peak time. This was a population of 370 individuals,
and the paper came out in energy policy around
this and you can see here for example TV is
watched 90 during the peak time, etc. And in
black, that's kind of the willingness to shift
what percentage of people were willing to
shift, and you can see that just very few items
like your washer, dryer, dishwasher are things
that both meet somewhat being used in the
peak time, and somewhat willing to shift. So
this started shaping a lot of our groups thinking
on how to design the systems that respond
to this need, and I'll address that when we
talk a little bit about powernet, but I think
this kind of engagement and interaction with
consumers now they're doing a project where
we educate these households through their
kids to understand their own consumption from
smart meter data and then try to execute on
the shift. It's a little bit away from the
traditional path but it's all about how do
you have this human in the loop during this
kind of management, and it's a ton of work
and very interesting as well, so if you come
here in the summer, we have workshops with
you know, hundreds of kids and it's super exciting.
Okay, going more towards learning, you know
the first idea I feel is very critical is
that in economics, there's a gold standard
about how you learn preferences. You usually
say people have a utility function, I'm going
to show them different choices, observe the
choice they make, and then model this utility
function that is kind of the embedded value
of the choice. And there is lots of techniques
for that, and it's well known. This typically
translates in the utility world of electric
utilities, as we will do randomized trials
on different programs that we have, let's say
for demand response, to understand the size
of the effect, and then model the heterogeneity
of that effect as a function of customer characteristics
collected from questionnaires. It turns out
that these models in the electricity side
perform not so great. Typically if you use
created models like this and we work closely
for example with PG&E on looking at this and
then you say, now I want to recruit enough
customers to have a megawatt of demand response
on this particular feeder, you end up with
something like 10 to 20 percent of that. That's
kind of it, called the yield. Just as a point
of comparison you know if you go and talk
to somebody at amazon, they will say that these
offers that are put on your first landing
page of the amazon website when you see it,
75 of the people click on one of those offers
and then of those clicks, between 50 to 70
percent of the people actually purchased what
they saw. So that is overall much more than
like a demand response offer where you're
actually offering money to the customer, and
yet the engagement is less. Economists looked
at these questions in the last 10 years and
there's a really beautiful stream of literature
on that, and what they kind of found is that
this is called the issue with stated preferences
because normally, we are not able to observe
what actions customers take with regards to
their electricity consumption. So you do polls
and surveys like the one I had before, and
then use those polls and surveys to predict
how much flexibility customers have, and that
goes directly into the planning. And so those
predictions don't completely capture the preferences
because customers don't pay a lot of attention
to their electricity bill; it's not a big part
of their budget. So this is an issue not just
with electricity in many other areas declared
preferences of things that won't don't weigh
on your pocket as much are not accurate. So
one idea that we developed in partnership
with PG&E, ESE, and a host of utilities was this
idea that, well I have a smart meter that's
like high resolution temporal data. That data,
it's like an MRI of customers preferences.
If I could interpret that MRI, and by that,
here is what I mean, extract features like
what's the peak load, base load, what's the
thermal sensitivity, what are the load shapes,
I can use these features to build these models
for segmentation, targeting, etc. This gave rise to
a project called Wisdom which was carried
out here at Stanford from 2011 to 2016, and
then we released this open source package
called Wisdom it's now used in eight U.S utilities
in Southern California, Edison PG&E, Vermont,
etc, and then a few more worldwide. And it's
completely free, open source, you can download,
and i think in 2016 when we released it, we
had analyzed about 8 million smart meters
with this package. Since then you know we haven't
really kept track of what's going on, so
just as an initial, like, the very first result
from Wisdom is shown here. We just did the
first study ever at the time at the scale
that was done, which was 66 million customer
days. We looked at 66 million customer days
across the bay area and performed clustering.
And when we started doing this study, PG&E
gave us the data that took itself like a year
or two, and then when we did the study initially
the consensus was, well why should we do this,
it's well known in planning that all customers
are this dual peak shape. And then when we
actually did the clustering, we found many
different load shapes for each day, including
just consuming at night, very flat consumption,
evening peaks, and the so-called planning option.
It's only fourteen percent of the load shapes.
And this is very critical because, for example,
load shape number 811 here actually can have
demand response capability at 3 pm, versus
this guy here, 14, can have no such significant
capability. So first lesson from this project
is when you're thinking about these new kinds
of flexibility that are emerging, number one,
due to the preferences of consumers, the flexibility
may or may not be there, like you saw from
the survey. Number two, data and massive data
are essential to have accurate models of consumer
preferences to achieve the types of performance
we need to make these things cost effective
for the future. So the second question we had
in our list up there was, okay so we understand
customer preferences, maybe we can collect
a few of these consumers, and use their capabilities
to offer services back to the grid, or to reduce
their bill, or something like that. How do we
do that at scale? That was the genesis of this
project Powernet. It's a project that has been
funded by the California Energy Commission
and ARPA-E as part of the nodes program, and
we had as partners Zodian, Suntech drive and
Google. Google also funded the project and
it's also a partner of the technology. And
it started out with a simple, kind of interesting
observation. At the time we started this project
in my group and in Abbas El Gamal's, he's another
faculty here at Stanford, in his group we had
had a few collaborations around optimization
algorithms for storage and kind of distributed
control, and this is kind of a big fad in power
systems. And these algorithms work great in
Matlab, and that means in simulation, and then
you know, I visited Google and Arun Majumdar's
former group, the one that he created because
I had this kind of question that was put forward
by my student Gustavo, well, but how do we know
these algorithms actually work in the real
world? And then somebody told me Arun was doing
this in Google, and we went and visited that
group. And what they had tried was actually
to implement in a lab scale with realistic
constraints in terms of the cyber constraints,
the information exchange constraints, several
of these algorithmic strategies. And what they
found out is that fully distributed algorithms,
although very elegant and beautiful theoretically,
they don't really scale well, and it's very
hard to diagnose, it's very expensive to try
to set them up with customers, and so on. And
in fact at that time, they had just managed
to do like one home, and technologies inside
it and tried to coordinate the energy consumption.
And they had done a survey with customers
because they needed to collect preferences,
and Google does these user surveys, and they
said well, we're going to collect your preferences,
and here's our idea. We're going to put forward
a questionnaire with 50 questions that you
need to answer so we know everything we need
to know about how you like your house to be.
Like your temperature set point, and so on
so forth, and the result of the survey was
that the immense majority of people said they
would never use a system like that. I just
thought about my own home, there is the three
preferences for the thermostat set point, and
nobody can really agree on it, so that's an
example of you know trying to do that 50 times
is impossible. We decided when we went to look
at nodes, we wanted to propose a project which
was about building a real system that can
do such coordination, which addresses the scaling
issue, and that means really addressing three
critical problems at the same time. One problem
is whatever coordination mechanism you create,
its coordination is going to happen also through
the power network. In our case here we focus
on the distribution network. The second is
whatever mechanism you create needs to learn
and understand consumer preferences. In our
case we picked the consumer to be homes initially.
The preferences of the homeowner have to be
taken into account into the coordination. The
idea of picking up homes was also because
each home by itself cannot really provide
much value back to the grid, but in coordination
they can do a lot. And the third issue is that
whatever scheme you create, or architecture,
or solution you create needs to be able to
account for the real constraints out there
in terms of information exchange, so data exchange,
and communications, and so on. We spotted at
the time this notion of, well we can use the
cloud to do coordination. And for example this
is already done in data centers. So the cloud
runs the coordination of the communication
between the server racks, but the key idea
even in the data center case is the cloud
cannot do this in real time, because whenever
you put the cloud in a feedback loop there
is delays on the information exchange, there's
reliability issues if you try to make it geographically
spread, and this is all stuff we learned from
Google. So how do you do it so that the cloud
is not really at every second and every minute
calculating and sending the decisions to all
the homes. So that was this origin of this
project Powernet. Here's how the system that
we came up with was laid out. And again we
started this project in kind of an unusual
way because we decided to build a lab in Stanford,
put these devices and things together, work
with Google, connect everything to the cloud,
etc, without knowing what the solution was
going to be. And we experimented with tons
of algorithms until we figured something that
worked and that also had some theoretical
justification, but that is still kind of work
in progress, the theory around this. The key
idea of the system is that every home has
a smart hub, a local intelligence, it's a computing
capability that communicates digitally with,
you know, your inverters for the solar panel
storage, or EV chargers, and also with this
smart dimmer. This is a new kind of smart panel
that was designed by our colleague professor
Juan Rivas working with students. This panel
allows you to have high resolution measurements
of all of the sub-circuits of the home, but
also the capability to do voltage control
at the sub-circuit level. So you can have some
controllability of loads, appliances, and so
on, even without actually the appliance being
smart necessarily. So that's kind of the resources
you have, and normally this home would have
a bill, and it tries to minimize the bill using
data and these resources. But in order to minimize
the bill and also to do coordination, which
is homes might get together and say, well let's
shave the peak in this transformer because
we'll get some compensation from the hotel
market, or maybe directly from the utilities,
and from the demand response program. In order
to do all of that, they do need to understand
and account for the impact they will have
on transformer capacities and network voltages.
So that's kind of the setting, and how did
we solve this? I'm not going to enter into
a lot of details but I'll go a little bit
into this project. First, it required thinking
about this architecture, of how does the local
controllers and this kind of cloud coordinator
engage? And we also imposed ourselves this
issue that we want to minimize the information
exchange and the cloud cannot run in real
time. And so what we found is an architecture
that has a planning stage that's run every
24 hours in alignment with the day ahead market,
and in that planning stage it sends these
dynamic power bounds, so it's like establishing
a bandwidth for each one of the homes in terms
of each hour, how much power are they allowed
to draw or inject back into the grid. So instead
of having a static bound given by the transformer
they can have a dynamic bound. And it turns
out, if you do these calculations cleverly
this is enough to really protect the network
while enabling the coordination. We designed
this smart dimmer, we also did lots of algorithms
with data from predictions to learning the
customer preferences from observing their
choices and using appliances, and then the
biggest effort in the project was a massive
kind of deployment. So we had a large-scale
lab that was kind of built between Stanford
and slack, then we have deployments in a real
world farm and 20 homes in Fremont where we
put you know battery storage, solar, we read
their data, we kind of do all kinds of things.
I'm just gonna point out one thing here
and then move on. You know, the critical challenge
on the coordination is that there is a spatial
and temporal data asymmetry. It has not to
do just with the technical issues, it's because
who knows what information? The utility knows
the network, but doesn't necessarily have access
to behind the meter devices. DR providers have
access to their own devices, but no information
on the overall load or the utility network,
and so on. So how do you deal with this data
asymmetry? And so the design of Powernet addresses
this issue by figuring out how the information
needs to be shared, and how that shared information
is utilized so that we can maximize the benefits
for the consumers, their actual participants
in these systems. We initially -- when we designed
this system one of the things that we learned,
and I think this is kind of the first major
lesson, is seeking this kind of elusive optimality
that you see when you design algorithms and
you test them in simulations. It's actually
detrimental in designing real scalable solutions.
What we found is by sacrificing some of that
optimality, you can really take into account
all of these practical constraints and achieve
good results. So you can reduce the voltage
deviations that would result from people synchronizing
all their decisions. You can also do things
like offer ramping services, regulation services,
we showed all of those. And then if you look
at the end of the month into their bill, you
know you still achieve like 90 percent of
the ideal oracle reduction, so they can't even
achieve that in practice, but just that small
sacrifice results in big benefits. Here's kind of the
lab that we built and you can see this is
a lab that was a partnership between industry,
the Stanford school of engineering and ARPA-E.
So in industry the engagement was through
this Bits and Watts program that Liang directs.
And you can see here we have like a smart
home with real appliances, it's connected to
a panel, it's connected to a solar panel, to
a battery system, water heater, the whole thing,
and to an EV charger. This home is connected
to a home that's a little bit more virtual,
and here's like a grid emulator. All of this
system is connected to something like 10,000
virtual homes in gridlab D and open DSS now.
This whole lab is connected to a similar lab
in slack that had more of larger loads, and
were meant to emulate small and medium businesses.
And this is where we initially tried to design
our solutions and demonstrate them, and we
learned so much from first of all, interoperability.
Yes we do have the Sunspec alliance. But if
you try to go and read any information from
real inverters, it doesn't really work. We did
the field tests, and we have successfully deployed
this system in a farm, and then now we are
doing it in homes in Fremont. You can see here
the cooling of cows in this real dairy facility
is one of the largest dairy facilities in
the united states, and they spend about $200,000
every summer with this cooling. And what
we are able to show is that using Powernet
you can reduce about 50% of that cost. And what
Powernet does is it coordinates storage, the
solar panels on the rooftop of the barns, and
the fan control, and tries to maintain the
cow temperatures appropriately right now using
airflow measurements, but we have installed
like a thermal camera. So as you can see in
the system I use this as an example because
there's a lot of embedding of IOT solutions
from different vendors and so on. I'm just
going to wrap up with our latest project. So
after we did Powernet, we realized there are
a lot of principles on how you should design
the software solution for this and the architecture.
And we wanted to look into how to do this
at an even larger scale. And we partnered up
with folks in computer systems design here
at Stanford, and decided to look into this
issue of virtualization, modularity, and layering,
which is their principles of how they do computer
systems design. And that gave source to this
project called trustDER. The goal is to ensure
resource virtualization, security ,and privacy
for all of these algorithms by virtualization.
It's a simple concept: can you take one resource
and make it look like many virtual resources,
or many resources and looking as one from
a software perspective, so then you write your
solutions you don't have to worry about this.
And then in the privacy and fairness it's
all about really protecting the privacy of
the customer. If I have to have data privacy
how do I design algorithms? It turns out to
be pretty difficult to do that. To conclude,
I just wanted to leave the form of engagement
we have had through all these projects is
using this affiliate model for partnerships
through the Bits and Watts program. We work
very closely with companies, gathering their
inputs, having them participate in board of
advisors, and in some cases directly join our
research teams, and students who finish these
projects sometimes go on to develop these
technologies commercially, sometimes they go
into these companies as employees, and so on
so forth. I also have a flagship program that
was started through this partnership around
EVs. Thank you very much.
[ANITA]: Thank you Ram for
sharing with us some of your work. We have
a few questions that were submitted. The first
question is high level, then we'll dig a little
deeper. To start, would you take a few minutes
to explain how DER measures and grid digitalization
affect grid resilience?
[RAM]: In terms of the resiliency,
I think there is two key ideas. One is understanding
how do you translate consumer flexibility
into resiliency, because what is resiliency?
How do you measure it? For example, if I have
an earthquake in San Mateo, it will affect
the homes. It might disrupt some of the solar
PV, it might affect part of the grid. What do
I mean by being resilient? Do I have to provide
full power to the remaining homes, or is it
part power, does it depend on the intensity
of the event? We collaborated with the faculty
who does earthquake engineering to try to
define these metrics around the ERs. And it
turns out there's two key aspects in my mind.
One is you need to understand something like
what is the full load potential, half load
potential, no load potential of each customer.
The second one I think it's it's a lot harder,
which is really, any system to be resilient
beyond its individual capability, there is
this notion of a networked resiliency. And
that means you need to understand how to model
the switching in the distribution systems,
and adding those switches, as well as how does
damage due to different events affect those
systems. I think it's a fairly open question.
From a broader utility perspective I think
there is yet another question. Once you have
a resiliency model you need to know what resources
are out there today in terms of DERs. From solar
panels to different equipment, and the mapping
of this has been lagging tremendously. This
data is hard to access, often unavailable. In
Stanford which started a project called the
Stanford energy atlas that uses satellite
imagery, we work with people in machine learning
and so on, and do country-wide mapping of these
resources. But there's many such efforts now
that are happening, and I think without that
it's impossible to do this resiliency assessments.
[ANITA]: Excellent, thank you. For our next question,
would you talk about time resolution of cloud
coordination? What is time resolution, then
would you go deeper into that? Also, could you
talk about the optimization model and how
you deal with changing household preferences?
[RAM]: Overall, the idea is in the cloud coordinator
itself. We run it five to 15 minutes, so when
you're offering ramping services, etc, but locally
we run it between a minute and a second. We
have tried all of those combinations; the minute
seems to be more than enough. The optimization
we started with STP Conic optimization to
take into account the network obviously required
a lot of magic to make it work with like tens
of thousands of homes and large feeders, but
recently we moved to the idea of successive
linearization, which despite the absence of
strict performance guarantees, in all of our
practical examples and real feeder systems
that we got from a few utility partners it
has done a really amazing job, and it's super
fast.
[ANITA]: Super, and I appreciate that insight. Next,
would you talk about what is the potential
for developing local energy markets, distribution
operational markets as distinct from wholesale
market opportunities, and how those distinctive
opportunities can be optimized?
[RAM]: If you look
not just today, but if you're looking at the
same grid 10 years from now, for example, you'll
have much deeper penetration of EVs, you know
particularly kind of delivery vehicles
and things like that that pull a lot of power,
and you will need to start managing the impact
of this power on the distribution network
much more intelligently than today. Today there
is a big slack capacity on the distribution
system so we are taking advantage of that.
If you go beyond the united states and look
at other countries for example in India, or
in Brazil, distribution transformers are often
already overloaded, and adding chargers is
kind of a difficult thing because there is
no benefit for the flexibility that is monetized.
[ANITA]: Great! And for our final question, there is
an interest in understanding what role universities
play in the pipeline to invent and develop
new technologies, approaches, and solutions.
And then to add to that, what needs do you
have to take the work that you and your teams
have been doing from research and initial
concepts to commercialization and adoption?
[RAM]: I think that first and foremost the mission
of the university is education, and I think
a gigantic role is preparing students who
can go and address these challenges in the
real world for all the companies, and policy
making, and so on out there. There's kind of
the set of knowledge, the knowledge base they
need to have to address these problems in
future energy systems is very different from
the past. You're not designing, you know, transmission
lines anymore, you're talking about IOT, and
communications, and distributed algorithms
and things like that, but also policy, economics,
social sciences. So I think that is kind of
a first, and I really found a lot of success
with the students at Stanford and at other
institutions. The second I think point that
is very critical is the university can serve
almost like as a neutral zone where all these
different stakeholders can meet and exchange
ideas, exchange information, exchange data, and
work together on problems. It's like a neutral
ground because you know the mission is education,
and is not for profit organization. With that
mindset, we have done a lot of the projects
that you see here. It came out of conversations
with the industry with very close interactions
with them but with typically with companies
that don't talk to each other, and then also
policy makers and so on. And another example
of that is at Stanford, we have hosted lots
of interesting data sets where we collaborate
in teams so that the owner of the data set
is aware of all that's going on, but that has
led to really useful tools, like Wisdom is
an example of that, so shared data. And I think
that the last piece, and this is something
that I think we need to improve from the universities,
is really the awareness around these problems.
I think in the US today, you see young people
much more in tune with the notions and ideas
around sustainability, wanting a 100% renewable
grid, but the a deeper understanding of all
of the actual issues, the scale of what this
transformation means, and then motivating people
to go and study this, get involved, and work
in this industry, I think that's something
universities can do certainly a better job
of. I think this commercialization side is
often misunderstood because I think the source
of a lot of the interesting ideas is out of
thinking about, you know, the fundamentals. And
out of that it manifests itself sometimes
as software, sometimes as just the people. And
somebody asked about, you know, what's kind
of the challenge to commercialization. Having
done startups that came out of Stanford in
other areas and comparing them to energy, I
think there is two really important challenges.
One is energy systems are very critical,
and today they are extremely reliable. So the
time scales at which you need to do a startup
are very different. And this actually offers
an opportunity for new types of partnerships
where companies can identify interesting technologies
developed in Stanford or Dartmouth, and then
co-invest, and with the university and there's
many different models that are being explored
to kind of bridge that time scale. There's
also programs like the one in Berkeley the
cyclotron road that helps you do that launch.
I think the second challenge -- and this I think
it's much more key -- as a community in grid,
we don't really do an excellent job of keeping
what are kind of important practical problems,
that if addressed, there will be a ton of interest.
If you go and you're working with medical
data, or you're thinking about data centers,
each one of these communities has it very
clear, what are some like target problems that
can be worked on by companies, researchers,
and so on.
[ANITA]: Thank you, Ram, for this very informative
and impactful presentation. I want to thank
all of you for viewing this today. As you can
see in your screen, if you would like to learn
more about the EIET 237: Transforming the
Grid course and the other courses offered
as part of the Stanford online Energy Innovation
and Emerging Technologies program, you can
follow the links on this page, and there are
other buttons on the screen as well. If you
found this presentation to be helpful in any
way we, encourage you to share the recording
with your colleagues, friends, and family, or
whoever you think will find this useful. Thanks
for taking the time to join today, and have
a great rest of your day.